The Olympic Tug-of-War... and 8 Other Sports
Facts
1) About 5% of all Association Football (Soccer)
injuries occur during celebrations after scoring
a goal.
2) Former Major League baseball player Benji
Molina was one of the slowest base runners
in baseball during his career.
So slow that he once hit a home run that he
never scored on, with a pinch runner put in
after Molina made it to first base…
What happened was Molina hit a home run that
initially was ruled a single and a pinch runner,
Emmanuel Burris, was put in.
However, manager Bruce Bochy challenged the
call and it was ultimately ruled a home run,
but because the pinch runner had already been
put in, the umpires ruled that Molina could
not go back out to complete the home run trot.
So Burris, not Molina, was given credit for
scoring the run, while Molina was credited
with hitting the home run.
This makes Benji Molina the only player in
MLB history to hit a home run and not score
on it.
3) Tug of war was an Olympic event until after
the 1920 Olympics.
Multiple teams from countries were allowed,
which is how the U.S. won bronze, silver,
and gold in 1904.
Britain did the same thing in 1908.
4) In 1996, when Pete Sampras played Alex
Corretja in the U.S. Open, he had a bit of
a stomach bug.
He actually threw up on the baseline during
the fifth set.
One of the referees warned Pete Sampras that
he would be disqualified if he caused another
delay.
Sampras pulled himself together and was not
only able to finish the match, but he came
out victorious.
5) Henry Chadwick, the creator of the baseball
box score, was the first to setup a demonstration
proving that the rotation of a baseball could
cause the ball to curve.
Before this, some pitchers had already observed
and used this to their advantage (even though
many of the day considered it cheating), but
no one had yet proved that it was actually
happening and not just in the pitcher’s
heads or an optical illusion.
To prove it, Chadwick set up two stakes placed
twenty feet apart in a line between the pitcher
and batter’s box.
A pitcher, Fred Goldsmith, then threw a ball
which ended up being to the right of the first
stake, but then curved to end up to the left
of the second stake.
6) Chadwick chose the “K” to denote a
strikeout in a baseball box score because
it was the last letter in “struck” as
in “struck out”.
Chadwick often liked to use the last letter
of words instead of the first, particularly
when he felt they were more memorable.
In this particular case, Chadwick said “the
letter K in struck is easier to remember in
connection with the word, than S.”
7) “Super Bowl” and “Super Sunday”
are trademarked by the NFL.
As a result of this, any advertisement, event,
promotion, etc. that wants to refer to the
Super Bowl has to come up with some colloquialism
or be granted rights to do so by the NFL,
which rarely happens.
For the Super Bowl, the most popular colloquialism
is “The Big Game”.
Once this became common, the NFL tried, unsuccessfully,
to trademark “The Big Game”.
8) Soccer balls were originally painted with
the now classic black and white checkered
look in order to make them more visible on
black and white TV during the 1970 FIFA World
Cup.
Naturally, people wanted to buy balls that
looked like those that the professionals used
on TV and thus everybody bought the black
and white checkered soccer ball instead of
the previous traditional solid color ball.
9) Mickey Rourke, most recently known for
his parts in Iron Man 2 and The Expendables,
shocked Hollywood back in the early 90s when
he decided to quit acting and become a professional
boxer.
Rourke intended to fight until he got a title
shot, but after three years and a series of
serious injuries he decided to quit.
However, he did manage to retire undefeated
with 6 wins and 2 draws, joining an elite
club of boxers who retired undefeated such
as the great Rocky Marciano and arguably the
greatest super middleweight boxer of all time,
Joe Calzaghe.